Here in Rangiora, we've been discussing
the concept of a Civic Precinct.
Now that involves the expansion of the Rangiora
Library here and the main Council building.
This would allow the library to
cater for our growing population
and would enable the creation of community spaces
for things like art displays or even a museum.
The upgrade would also better
accommodate staff currently
spread across six different buildings in Rangiora.
The Council's preference is to put
this project on hold until 2028,
now that's going to help keep debt
and rates down in the short term.
Other options include accelerating
the funding and construction of
the combined civic precinct building
or shelving the project altogether.
Visit waimakariri.govt.nz/letstalk to take
a look at the options and to have your say.